oh this has this guy's got just
an app oh and we finally get the white
pieces
so maybe the platform is not rigged
after all
and this guy got some epic profile
picture so
i um after long
thoughts and studying my openings i have
to do this one game
um i just started chest ball course and
they claimed it was winning for white so
who am i to argue here the best players
in the world are doing it so
i am joining the hype train
um let's see
f4
probably the best move is like king e1
back
i have to um okay f4 looks too
aggressive but why not
none of three and now in fact it's not
looking so bad
i am starting to enjoy this opening
okay knight g for check i'll just go to
g1 and
and um h3 next so it's fine
and if there's no direct um idea here
maybe c4 is dangerous
i should have taken that into account i
sort of saw it but
i thought i had some like d4 or
something
okay now we just develop and it's
looking fine
what are my favorite openings well this
is uh certainly one of them by now i
didn't um
know it too well yet but i'm i'm i've
seen other
strong players employ it and i haven't
seen white losing with this opening
before so um
this is starting to become one of my
favorite openings
otherwise it's hard i like to play
in fact all kind of openings in all
honesty and um
i'm really open-minded in that sense
that i don't have a specific
favorite opening but of course there's
some openings i lean towards more like a
sharp sicilian is always nice or
any kind of sharp interesting opening
why not have you ever considered going
into competitive chess boxing
i have not but i know the sport exists
and
[Music]
it kind of seems like interesting but i
would get beaten up so
bad so i would have to join that
to go to the gym like um
and even then like i'm just um
a slim boy right i have no chance but
it's a it's fun sport i've seen some
clips and stuff
okay let's close the position
and go back with the bishop
um sometimes to get a good position
you have to retreat your pieces a little
bit and um
that's what i'm doing here and i got
this real nice block on
e3 the only thing missing is rook on f1
that would be a nice addition
so and sometimes you can also just take
pawns
okay he's threatening to take on c2 then
i've got rook e1
or bishop d3 it should be fine
it should be fine
okay see you monkey king you taught
me a lot today so thanks for that
okay so queen takes c2 i guess bishop d3
or do i have any other tricks oh wait i
only have 30 seconds we cannot
have this game be in vain and kng2
rook hc1 connector rooks and um
it is looking fine to me
i can't take on e7 but
i prefer um developing
i'm not playing this great but it's all
right
he's he's speeding up he knows he uh
he can beat me on time here
rook a6 what
that was surprising
okay now up a piece this should be
relatively easy
if i can stop his counter play queen c4
seems i don't want to take on c6 because
queen takes d3
okay let's go for checkmate
and i think i got this one although
i should not speak too soon wait how
what what's the mate after queen takes
the tree though
like okay i see an easy win there
yeah this seems easy enough
you have knight xb8 xb808 and now
i'll win this easily bishop d4
and the bomb cloud prevails one more
time
all righty that was a nice game in fact
i think
i am happy and um
strangely enough just24 recommends me
the doretsky and game manual
fifth edition by aaron lamey but i don't
think there was much of an end game in
this game
and um well it is surely an interesting
course i don't think it's quite fitting
but